hello everyone happy new year
although it's a couple of days late this
is still a perfectly good time to sit
down um drink a cup of hot chocolate
because it's also a good time to treat
yourself and reflect on the past year
and set our intentions for the year
going forward
i'm sure you've been bombarded with
videos just like this one
but trust me this one's going to be
really really good here we go the 10
biggest lessons i learned in 2021 that
i'm taking into 2022.
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dami and i'm
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc on this channel we talk
about architecture and design and some
tools and strategies that can help us
have more meaningful and fulfilling
careers in architecture so the first
lesson has to do with protecting your
time um specifically your deep work time
so when i was doing my end of year
reflections i realized that holy sh
the channel grew from a thousand to a
hundred thousand subscribers this year
and thank you for that of course it's
not just about the metrics
it's been an incredibly fulfilling year
and i feel like i've really grown as a
human being
and as a professional
and if there's one thing like one single
thing that's really propelled this
growth for me and made all of this
possible while by the way having a
pretty demanding full-time job as an
architect it is my two and a half hours
of morning deep work sessions before i
officially start work so when i started
this youtube channel i felt like i was
doing a million things
but i didn't really feel like i was
making a lot of progress
you might have noticed that my posting
schedule was pretty
sporadic
in the early days of the channel then i
came across this idea of deep work
from a book called deep work by cal
newport
where he argues that the ability to do
deep work is one of the most valuable
and rare skills in this super
competitive economy
and if there's one skill we should try
to actively develop right now it's the
ability to do deep work deep work is the
ability to do focused work uh without
distraction on tasks that are
cognitively demanding
and a deep work session is anywhere
between one to four hours of continuous
undisturbed work on a single task if
you're interested in learning more about
this topic i have a full video on it
i'll leave it right here so since my
evenings are usually a little bit of a
mess with my work schedule i set up my
deep work sessions right in the mornings
and i tried this for 90 days at the
beginning of the year
and it's had a pretty big impact on my
life i would say i was able to make
videos pretty consistently
and i didn't really feel the need to do
work in the evenings because i'd already
finished my most important tasks i've
actually never really considered myself
a morning person after doing this
consistently i've kind of come to truly
really
enjoy these first two hours my day to
become kind of a non-negotiable for me
the second lesson is called the 80
rule and it has to do with perfectionism
james clear talks about the story in his
book atomic habits
where a photography professor divided
his class into one side would be the
quantity group they will be graded on
the amount of work they produced
and the other side would be the quality
group and they would be graded on the
excellence of their work meaning if they
wanted an a they had to create an almost
perfect image at the end of the year he
found that all of the best photos were
produced by the quantity group because
these students were taking photos every
single day and they were experimenting
and they were like testing the light
conditions and the composition and that
process helped them hone their skills
and the quality group on the other hand
um instead of iterating they just spent
a lot of time speculating on what a
perfect image is and in the end they had
very little to show i really love the
story um but
if you are a perfectionist this can kind
of put you in a trap of like
trying to make a large quantity of
perfect work even though i know deep
inside that there's like diminishing
returns the longer i work on something
it's just hard to define a stopping
point but then i read this thing about
aiming for 80 before you show up a
product
and when i heard that i was like damn
that's like pretty helpful i think
putting a number to it like that it just
makes your stopping point a lot more
concrete you can be more okay with
shipping out an imperfect product
especially when you're starting out
focusing on the quantity over quality i
think is pretty important because the
way you get good
is like producing something
and iterating it and learning from it i
think if i didn't follow this rule i
probably would have only made like 10
videos this year and probably would have
lost steam pretty early because
what i found is that you can always find
something wrong with your work
especially with your videos but actually
other people rarely notice these
problems they only seem to notice other
weird little details
the third lesson has to do with the role
models having a list of role models have
helped me in navigating my career and
thinking in a lot of different ways up
till now
most of my role models have been other
successful architects and sometimes
professors
mainly because becoming an architect has
taken up such a huge chunk of my life as
i expanded my area of interest into
things like entrepreneurship or
spirituality
or living intentionally i realized that
this list of role models was actually
really limiting and not really helping
me navigate certain decisions and just
like ultimately not really contributing
to me becoming a more
well-rounded person it sounds obvious
but people who are great architects are
not necessarily the best people to
follow for some of these other things
like being a good friend or being a good
person
and
secondly i realized that the super
successful architects that i looked up
to
grew up in a time and economic climate
that was like vastly different from mine
so as i progress in my career and into
my other interests i've been finding it
harder to relate to them
especially since we're living in such
unprecedented times i've been trying to
spend a little bit more time trying to
build out a slightly more holistic list
of role models that can guide me in
these other areas of my life
the fourth lesson has to do with the
rest my resting times were times i
wasn't working by default and i never
spent a lot of time thinking about rest
but this year i watched a few of my
close friends and colleagues go through
burnout especially with
me like starting a new youtube channel
and
taking some of my other side activities
more seriously i realized that if i
wasn't more intentional with my rest
my schedule wasn't gonna magically open
up for me to rest that my resting time
didn't really help me recharge my
batteries i also realized that i was
gonna burn out inevitably by scheduling
my breaks directly into my calendar as a
non-negotiable activity i know it sounds
really simple but it really helped me to
restrategize on my work and
schedule things around it
and it also forced me to think about the
activities that would actually help me
recharge my batteries and
help me optimize my rest sometimes
that's going for a hike and sometimes
that's watching the office for the 50th
time i also found that being able to see
my resting days directly in my calendar
gave me a kind of sense of control and a
kind of appreciation for the work that i
was doing the fifth lesson has to do
with chunking time i've always
automatically chunked time into 30
minute to one hour increments for
example if i had a meeting from 8 30 to
9 30 and the meeting ended early like at
9 10 i had another meeting scheduled for
like 9 30 i would just like
check my phone and like wait around for
that meeting
then i kind of came across this idea of
chunking time into 15 minute increments
and i think i first came across this
idea from ali abdal
and i think that little shift in mindset
has had a pretty transformational effect
on me because i can actually be doing a
lot more things during that time so the
next lesson has to do with handling
adversities
this year
one of my colleagues that i've been
working pretty closely with quit uh with
like a one week notice
and i ended up having to pick up a lot
of her work because we've been working
very closely together on this one
project for a long time
as like two project architects
and as like two brains on the job this
was kind of terrifying and a little bit
stressful
and
kind of nerve-wracking and like all that
good stuff but a couple of weeks ago
the week before we left for holidays the
principles they wanted to have like an
early salary review and basically they
sat down and told me that they saw me
really grow this year and kind of let me
know how impressed they were about how i
handled the situation and managed the
project they actually ended up giving me
kind of a big salary raise
which was
a big surprise because
in my four years of working in the field
i'd never just like gotten a big raise
without asking for it this
was
kind of a
shitty situation for me when it happened
something like this has happened to me
quite a few times over the past few
years one of them i've mentioned on the
channel before
it was when i quit my job like just
before the pandemic to go on a yoga
retreat lol and yeah the market was like
it was not good
and i was like [ __ ] my pants for
like three months because i didn't know
if i was ever gonna get hired as an
architect again that is when i decided
to start this youtube channel now it's
giving me a pretty decent like side
income a lot of times things that seem
like really shitty situations end up
being really cool opportunities let me
know in the comments if something like
this has happened to you before i think
when shitty situations happen it's
really easy to play the victim game
being able to recognize adversities as
opportunities
is one of the most important life skills
you can develop the next lesson has to
do with self-reflection
i think there's two types of activities
there's the activities that we do really
enjoy doing that we can kind of see
ourselves doing for the rest of our
lives let's call this our permanent
activities and so for me that's things
like designing creating teaching
traveling and then there's the things
that we do in order to
get to something else in architecture
school i really really really didn't
like physics class but it was something
that i had to get through to get my
degree and become an archetype let's
call these
temporary activities i noticed that
things get a little murky as i started
getting paid for both of these
activities in certain instances these
like temporary activities were more
financially rewarding i think if you
really want to make progress towards a
happier and like a more meaningful life
journaling regularly and like asking
yourself what you really want out of
life and like identifying these
permanent versus temporary activities it
can really help you figure out what you
need to
double down on and what you need to
change
or at least work towards changing and i
think it forces you to ask yourself
things like like what are you willing to
sacrifice to continue doing these like
permanent activities like what are the
steps i need to take to
make a full income out of these
permanent activities the eighth lesson
has to do with how you think about time
so i first heard this idea from a book
called the happy sexy millionaire by
stephen barlett and he says well there's
24 hours in a day and let's say you
sleep for eight hours a day so you have
16 waking hours and 16 times 7 is 112
waking hours in a week he thinks about
life as a roulette table and those 112
hours are your chips you have 112 chips
every hour and you have to use it on
something there's a quote that i really
like in this book time is both free and
priceless the person you are now is a
consequence of how you used your time in
the past the person you'll become in the
future is a consequence of how you use
your time in the present spend your time
wisely
gamble with it intrinsically
and save it diligently
pretty smart guy this resonated with me
especially this year because
everyone says that architecture is a
lifelong profession where you're in the
learning phase for a really really long
time
as i come closer and closer to the
um
childbearing age should i say i've been
thinking about this and like the finite
nature of time i think thinking about
time like this at least helps you
protect your time a little bit better so
that you can focus on the things that
have long-term intrinsic value to you
the ninth lesson has to do with
confidence you know that saying fake it
till you make it
i've used this mantra for a long time um
when i was a fresh intern um and i had
to pretend to know my stuff in front of
consultants and clients i think this is
okay
when you're really early in your career
but actually i think it can kind of have
a damaging impact on your life because
it stops you from saying
i don't understand and try to learn in
that moment deep inside you know you're
a fraud i think we have to be okay with
our limits and okay with what we don't
know i think when you audit your skills
you'll find that yeah like i'm not good
at these things let's say i i was not
really good at construction detailing i
can be good at other things like i can
be really good at marketing and so
you'll feel more confident that you can
bring something unique to the table also
i heard this quote practice makes
confidence competence makes confidence
and i love this quote this is the first
year where i've noticed this shift in my
mindset and
my posture and how i interact with the
world and i think if you spend the time
to actually learn things properly and
become competent in your skills
confidence is going to come naturally
and the final biggest lesson i learned
this year has to do with
self-observation
i recently came across this book called
the art of happiness by the dalai lama
and the psychiatrist called howard color
and it's like an intro to spirituality
but even if you're not into that stuff
it actually gives you
really practical solutions to problems
that we kind of deal with every single
day there's some really good lessons in
this book the dalai lama he's a pretty
smart guy
but
one of the things that's had a big
impact on me this year is the idea of
analyzing your thoughts and
motives as if you're looking at yourself
from a third person's point of view one
of the biggest breakthroughs for me
was that i actually
kind of had this like subconscious
victim mentality and that's been having
a really negative impact on my life and
i was completely unaware of this
until i started actively observing my
thoughts and why i was feeling certain
emotions i think when we understand
something or someone we can feel a lot
more empathy towards that person even if
it's a liar or a murderer if we
understand that person's upbringing and
why he or she is the way he is you're
kind of like
okay i mean
that's really shitty what he did but i
kind of understand that's a long way of
saying if we understand ourselves and
why we are the way we are we can come a
little closer to loving ourselves for
who we are and i know that's kind of a
mushy statement so i apologize i think
if we truly want a happy and meaningful
life i would classify
self-examination and self-compassion and
like self-love as one of those keystone
habits that's gonna make everything else
fall into place self-observation
game changer
thank you so much for watching guys i
hope you guys have an awesome awesome
start to the new year if you're
interested in other self-help type of
videos i actually don't have any other
self-help type videos on this channel
but
i would highly encourage you to check
out some of my other videos on
architecture which actually have a big
impact on your happiness i'll leave you
some of my favorite videos right here if
you're interested in this topic and want
more let me know in the comments below
also if you want a monthly email from me
where i share things i'm reading or
learning
sign up for my newsletter i hear it's
pretty pretty pretty good i'll leave the
link below and with that i hope you guys
have an awesome incredible fabulous
start to a new year but even if it's
mundane that's totally okay yours is
pretty overrated anyways all right i'll
see you guys in the next video bye
[Music]
you